[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
former government officials now
criminally charge for the deadly flint
water crisis
how prosecutors brought cases against
nine defendants
including the former governor finally
finally holding people accountable
for their alleged unspeakable atrocities
jacob blake is speaking out
about the officer-involved shooting that
left him paralyzed
and why the conviction of the suspect in
the shooting death of a former nfl
player
was overturned plus investigations in
the capitol ride are growing
our look into how social media posts are
being used to track suspects
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
former top ranking government officials
in michigan are now facing criminal
charges over the flint water crisis
damaging effects on children that will
follow them for generations to come
we didn't put a price tag or come in
with a certain
list of charges more than 80 people were
sickened and 12
died after the city changed his drinking
water from a treated source
to the flint river in 2014. prosecutors
now say
actions by government officials were
criminal this case is about justice
truth accountability poisoned children
lost lives shattered families that are
still not whole
and simply giving a damn about all of
humanity
a grand jury indicted nine individuals
for a total of 42 counts
including former governor rick snyder
for two misdemeanors
of willful neglect and two former heads
of the michigan department of health and
human services
for involuntary manslaughter nicholas
lyon
former director of mdhhs is charged with
nine counts of involuntary manslaughter
for each a 15-year felony and one count
of willful neglect of duty
a one-year misdemeanor eden wells
former chief medical executive is
charged with nine counts of involuntary
manslaughter each a 15-year felony
and one count of willful neglect of duty
in addition
she is charged with two separate counts
of misconduct in office
pre-incidences of preventing or
attempting to prevent
the distribution of public health
information scientists learned lead from
aging pipes
leaked into the city's water supply the
possible source of a deadly legionnaires
disease outbreak
the grand jury proceedings are secret
but prosecutors say their team reviewed
millions of documents and hundreds of
electronic devices
one of these resources included in
enlisting a group of world-renowned
infectious disease experts to study the
deaths
in this case in the study of the deaths
in flint they were potentially
related to legionella it is critical
that this team to this team that did
these best be reviewed by
unbiased highly qualified professionals
these experts individually reviewed each
case and made an independent
determination
as to each and every cause of death
the nine defendants including the former
governor were booked into jail and then
appeared in court for their virtual
arraignment
governor schneider is the first former
governor since william milliken
who's remained in the state of michigan
he's not a risk of flight or a danger to
the community
and he's facing two misdemeanor charges
with the standard conditions including
that he personally appeared for any
future court hearings just for the
record of course your honor not guilty
charges are or please on each charge
thank you how will your client be
pleading today
not guilty to all accounts we
respectfully request
the court order a personal recognizance
bond
before the court is a 50 year 52 year
old
gentleman who was born and raised in
michigan he's lived here his entire life
with the exception of four years
his first job was with the department of
attorney general and had a career
from the one of the lowest positions in
state government
to the director of the largest state
agency the court does get to consider
the serious
nature of the allegations and uh with
nine count of involuntary manslaughter
court does take that very seriously and
at this time i will grant the request of
the people i will set a 200 000 cash
surety bond
joining me now is attorney dina dahl
along with terry austin
dina for those in flint these charges
were a long time
coming but what do you make of the
former governor snyder only facing
misdemeanor charges
and not involuntary manslaughter like
the others
i know it's going to be disappointing
for a lot of people it is important to
know though that he's the first michigan
governor in its history to be charged
with
a crime relating to its official conduct
so that's important to know and
basically they didn't have the evidence
what they charged them with
was that he didn't oversee his
appointees properly which means to me
that there must have been something that
said if he had been able to oversee
that his appointees must have given him
ev you know some sort of statement that
he relied on and that's why they weren't
able to charge them with the involuntary
manslaughter or they didn't have enough
proof
makes sense now terry being guilty in
the eyes of the public and guilty in
court are two
different things as we both know but do
you see guilty verdicts in these
officials future
you know brian if there were civil
charges against
these individuals whether it's the
governor or whether it's the health
officials
they would be able to defeat those
charges because they could assert some
sort of
sovereign immunity but the criminal
charges are going to be a little bit
more difficult because if there's any
causal connection
between their actions and the death of
these individuals
they could very well be convicted i
think ultimately
the city state they should have some
sort of
settlement because to your point that
would help the public
perception now dina could you see some
of these potential defendants
cooperating
and testifying against each other and do
you think anyone in particular will do
so
yes i do think it's possible i mean
there's definitely an incentive here
there's 14 years at stake and felony
charters
for people who over you know public
servants and they've obviously
failed at their job but they don't want
to end up as felons
and so yes i do think that there's a
possibility that there could be some
shared information absolutely we'll keep
an eye on that
still ahead on law and crime daily the
strange request from
jail from one defendant charged with
killing an unarmed jogger
but first the man shot by a police
officer seven times
is speaking out how jacob blake says the
shooting impacted his life
after the break
[Music]
the man shot seven times by wisconsin
police officer is speaking out in an
exclusive interview with abc news
jacob blake remains paralyzed following
the august 2020 shooting in kenosha
police were responding to a domestic
dispute when blake's ex-girlfriend
called 911 for help
investigators say blake was armed with a
knife and rule the officer's use of
force was justified
blake told good morning america's
michael strahan that his children
witnessed the incident
seven times i kind of went limp and
all i remember at that point was kind of
leaning back
looking at my boys i said daddy love you
no matter what i thought it was going to
be the laugh
i thought it was going to be the last
thing i say to them
thank god it wasn't
blake shooting led to protest in kenosha
that turned deadly
now prosecutors want conditions of bond
to be stricter for the man charged with
killing two people and injuring a third
eighteen-year-old kyle renton house is
accused of drinking at a bar with his
mother
wearing a shirt that says free as f and
flashing a white supremacist symbol
wisconsin allows for people under the
age of 21 to carry and drink alcohol
if they are with a parent rent house is
currently out on a two million dollar
bond
for charges of homicide and attempted
homicide he previously pled
not guilty
iran i would acknowledge receipt of the
information
waive the reading of the information i
have went over all the potential
penalties with my client he's aware of
them
i've also e-filed um a jury demand on
count six for a six person jury and
the 36 dollar fee earlier today
all right thank you uh i assume then at
this point you're going to be entering
please
yes prepare to enter not guilty please
to all the charges contained there and
all right thank you very much not guilty
please to all accounts contained in the
information are noted and
entered for the record matters shall now
be counted for further proceedings
before the honorable bruce e schrader
presiding
and any and all previously imposed bond
conditions and
issues of bail have remained in full
force and effect do you understand that
mr rittenhouse
uh yes sir attorneys terry austin and
dina dahl are back with me
guys maybe it's the canadian in me
that's been drinking legally since
19 but these requests to me at least
seem unconstitutional
now terry equal protectional law if a 21
year old was arrested for murder
bailed out and had a beer no prosecutor
would be asking for more bail
restrictions
so why the problem here if rittenhouse
legally consumed alcohol you know
brian the original bail conditions
did not include restricting the alcohol
or
restricting him from going into a bar or
fraternizing
and frankly i don't think there's any
legal basis to have those types of
restrictions
i think they are just trying to make
a point and for optic reasons they're
trying to say
look you can't go out you can't drink
you can't fraternize you can't wear
anything
on your clothing that looks as though
you might be associated with white
supremacy
frankly i don't think it's going to
prevail yeah let's talk about that
association
first amendment freedom of association
allows a person to peacefully assemble
how is having a beer with proud boys not
protected assembly
i think it is protected assembly if they
thought that this somehow was inciting
some sort of
future riot or some sort of violence you
know because of what happened last week
at the capitol
then they could go ahead and charge him
with something like that or if his
original
charge wasn't just murder but had
something to do with
white supremacy and organizing something
you know
also again in relation to violence then
this would make more sense but we are
still
innocent until proven guilty in this
country and you can't take away
people's rights just because you happen
to not like who they are associating
with or what they're doing
exactly not terry with all of this that
we're just discussing
ultimately how do you see the judge
ruling on these added restrictions for
bond
well i hope the judge looks at this from
a legal perspective and a constitutional
equal protection perspective
and denies the motion i think as much as
i disagree written house
should be able to drink exactly as well
as association with people even if i do
disagree with those people personally
now to georgia where one of the suspects
charged with killing an unarmed jogger
wants to be released from jail due to
high blood pressure
william rhodey bryan is charged with the
february 2020 death of a mod aubry
brian's attorneys are asking for a
second bond hearing
saying he needs outside medical
treatment a trial date has not yet been
set
but brian's attorney said his ability to
attend and participate meaningfully
if he survives would be greatly impaired
investigators say brian helped to block
in
and film the shooting co-defendants
travis and gregor mcmichael
also remain in jail pending trial
coming up on law and crime daily what
new leads investigators are pursuing
to find suspects of the capital
insurrection plus
will a man convicted of killing a pro
football player face a new trial
the supreme court decision that's
overturning a jury's verdict
the u.s supreme court has thrown out the
conviction of a man in the killing
of a former professional football player
northern st
defensive end will smith was shot to
death in 2016.
a jury found cardell hayes guilty of
manslaughter in a 10-2 vote
but the nation's highest court has
overturned that conviction saying
non-unanimous verdicts are
unconstitutional
police said hayes shot smith after a car
crash and argument
we located mr smith partially inside of
his vehicle
suffering from multiple gunshot wounds
to his body
he was later pronounced dead on the
scene we also found his wife who had
been shot to the right leg
she was taken to the hospital where she
was treated for non-life-threatening
injuries
based on our investigation we learned
that mr smith and his wife were
traveling eastbound on sophie wright
place
in their silver mercedes as they were
approaching felicity street their
vehicle was hit
in the rear by an orange hummer h2
which caused their vehicle to hit the
rear of a grey chevrolet impala
the impala was occupied by two
acquaintances of the victims
they were not injured at some point the
driver of the hummer later identified as
30 year old
cardell hayes and smith exchanged words
shortly afterwards hayes produced a
handgun
and opened fire on smith and his wife
back with me our attorneys dina dahl and
terry austin terry
unanimous jury verdicts are standard
among most states in the country
is this georgia simply joining the rest
of the country
yeah i think so brian i think they're
trying to catch up with the rest of the
country you know the supreme court ruled
in a famous case ramos
versus louisiana in 2020 that you must
have a unanimous vote of the jury under
the sixth amendment if you're going to
convict someone on a criminal charge
this was really viewed as a win for
civil rights advocates because they
argue that if an individual is going to
be deprived
of their liberty it really should be a
unanimous decision so
i think this is just georgia law
catching up with supreme court law
now dina looking at the prosecutors in
terms of strategy 10 to two to convict
do you get the sense another trial is on
the horizon
to try to make unanimous conviction
yes the ten to two is definitely in the
prosecutor's favor only two of them
wanted to acquit him
this is very similar to an essence a
hung jury
and i think another trial is definitely
on the horizon as long as all of the
witnesses are still available from the
first trial as long as the evidence is
still there
i think that they're going to bring the
case again yeah and of course this isn't
that
far off terry would you agree potential
another trial on the horizon in this
case
absolutely this is a serious case and i
think they should try it again to get a
unanimous
you know verdict yeah and of course
we've covered trials in the past
often times that retrial many of us
think that the advantage goes to the
prosecutor so they'll definitely be
hungry
for another trial thank you both when we
come back
new new information of the chaos at the
capitol how defendants own social media
posts
are being used against them in court
next
[Music]
a former navy seal from ohio is under
investigation for his part
in the chaos and violence at the capitol
something he appeared to brag about
as angenetta levy tells us that man has
a new message posted on facebook
adam newbold says he organized a caravan
to join other protesters in washington
d.c on january
6th but he was not planning to take over
the government or the capitol
he posted a video on facebook a day
before the incident
number one the police are not our
enemies i've already expressed that but
i want to make clear the police are not
our enemies the next day newbold was in
the crowd at the protest that later
turned violent at the u.s capitol
but in a video posted that night newbold
said he was proud of what happened at
the capitol
and that you had to destroy doors and
windows to get in
newbold owns atg worldwide a company
that teaches self-defense and home
defense along with concealed carry
classes
he also claims to be a government
contractor
in the video posted this week he said
that he said some nasty things and he
did not agree with people
fighting with police or trying to harm
them and that some people were actually
trying to de-escalate the situation the
whole capital
uh situation that was a an extremely
volatile extremely dangerous
thing that thousands and thousands of
people
were the whole entire crowd pushed it
down that way
and it was a a moment
of a long time it wasn't a moment in
time it
lasted for hours where there were
huge concerns and attempts to be a part
of the solution not a part of the
problem
but at the same time to say that that i
didn't feel a sense of pride as
americans
finally were standing up to take back
our country
that i believe and so many believe has
been stolen
but i do not believe that all those
people are domestic terrorists
i do not agree with that that is not my
position that is not my stance they are
not treasonous adam newbold said that he
believes the country is doomed
he told abc news that he is cooperating
with the fbi investigation
he has not returned my messages seeking
comment
for law and crime daily i'm angenette
levy
thanks antoinette federal authorities
continue to make arrests including an
olympic swimmer and two virginia police
officers
the initial charges everyone's familiar
with the the zip tie guys the munchols
and uh the brocks that were rested on
this on the
on the house floor with zip ties rifling
through the house floor
people are familiar with online they see
the uh
barnett's and johnson's who were
literally rifling through pelosi's
office and stealing items stealing
materials male and sometimes even
personal mementos we're looking at
significant felony cases tied to
sedition and conspiracy and it's going
to come into laser focus i think over
the next
weeks and days and i think people are
going to be shocked with some of the
egregious contact that happened within
the capital
now dina social media is not going to
help those charge
but do you see any defense for them here
or are these just open and shut cases
if there for a large group of people who
just trespass
a defense could be that they got
permission from capitol police some of
them
the barricaded were removed so that they
could walk by
but i want to say as shocking as it is
that it seems like some of these police
officers were involved
we shouldn't be so shocked because black
lives matter has been telling us for
years that there's some bad apples among
the ranks
we are all seeing that here you know so
we have we just didn't as a country do
enough about it beforehand
now terry with evidence so strong
against many of those charged partly
because of their social media
do you see these as trials or cases
where defendants are looking for plea
deals
you know they may be looking for plea
deals but i don't think the prosecution
has any appetite to
have any deals made here i think the
crimes were
so heinous and so outrageous and so
emblazoned
that they're going to take them to trial
particularly for those who
cause the death of the police officer
involved so
i don't think there's going to be any
deal there and brian also
the public outcry here has been so
great this was treasonous because they
ignored the fact that
we did have a lawful election and
they decided to storm the capital in any
event
agree terry but if they do go to trial
they're going to be tried by a jury of
their peers and there's at least
71 million of their peers that agree
that they're right
could you see a potential deadlock for
these trials across the country
you know anything is possible i think
most of the trials are going to be
held in dc in either state or federal
court
i think the other trials that are across
the country hopefully they will be able
to get juries who are impartial
and who don't make up their mind one way
or the other before they see
all of the evidence again we're just
watching how these charges roll out
how they end up being resolved or
whatever they
do trial or plea is going to be
interesting dina terry thank you for
joining us and thank you for joining us
here at law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you